I'm Rhett I'm Linc we're rhett and Link
and we're gonna share the last things on
our phones for Wired I took a picture of
me on a scale that my daughter made that
says yes she reengineered a scale oh and
it actually responds to your wait to
response to the way what questions did
you ask should I eat more yes last photo
on my phone is a picture of the back of
my head haha
I cut my own hair it's like how bad I
did look at that again nice you know I
cut that piece off after I like to this
photo what was I thinking
[Music]
that's like a video of me my son talking
to my dog there's a little embarrassing
what he's a puppeteer my son Lincoln
came up with the phrase and that's what
he says to the dog now I see it with the
puppeteer you should keep that between
you and your family please a puppet is
yeah
don't bring me into that I have a video
not me taking a leak like literally a
leak in a pipe I sent this to the pool
guy because sometimes he doesn't believe
me I'm not freakin lying to you man
[Music]
DIY how to make colors big poop milk
gummi pudding learn color slime plate
the ice cream did you search that learn
colors Play Doh Play Doh Play Doh I just
thought it was played duh really miss
build Play Doh yeah yeah I thought I was
just learning colors play does I already
know him
[Music]
Christmas sweaters that look like skin
which is scary no because we're gonna do
that in the Christmas party and I want
to do something that's creative I think
if you want to find out if you're a
serial killer just ask yourself have you
searched Christmas sweater made out of
skin Rhett texted me and said I'm here
and I'll Drive so he didn't respond I
got in the car with him we drove here
together my last text is that is amazing
ha in response to Katie but of but drugs
and Court in Indiana sent me a text that
they are now selling shirts that say but
liquors because they're selling liquor
at but drugs and it says but liquors and
she's like they're really doing well for
3637 a.m. 7:30 a.m. 737 am 737 that's
pretty precise only 23 minutes exactly
before 8 a.m.
well actually I needed I think it was 53
minutes
Oh number one is the fried shrimp I
don't use emojis hardly at all but we
had fried when you do you use the fries
I wanted to get fried shrimp and I sent
my wife a crap ton of fried shrimp in
one text and that was enough to make it
the most recently frequently used
because I don't really use emojis you
don't use emojis either the okay symbol
I never seek out emojis they seek me out
I'll just be I cuz I just type okay and
then it'll turn into that yellow then
you'll hit it you'll accept it he'll be
like yeah yeah that looks good any
minute after I sent it I'm like that
sexual suggester gesture it's the thing
where if you're writing a song and a key
and it shows you like oh the 16 chords
that you could play that would be in the
same key you gotta get it up no
my son you made a kissy face and he just
did like a modeling shoot thank you
phone he was eating breakfast he's got
like milk dripping up take one of me and
my dog here's a puppy dude I don't post
these anywhere by the way this is just
for me it's for myself that's why it's
called a selfie hip Christmas party on
Google play music music they played that
party Paul Anka oh he's good for rights
issues I'll just play the mouth trumpet
[Music]
that's exactly what it sounded like I
sent an email to myself of a picture
that I drew it looks like a man sitting
on a cornhole board with his crush next
to the hole and it says test a kill that
needs a no explanation